a good budget tells your money where to
go but an even better budget tells your
money when to go and that's what we're
doing here with Paycheck planning so
this person happens to get paid on
January 5th all right so we need to
decide what we can spend money on
between this paycheck and the next
paycheck right so she's got gas
groceries electricity miscellaneous
everything's looking good until we get
down here to mortgage and rent oh my
gosh she's going over there's not enough
money how can we rearrange this most of
us have kind of Chunk items on our
budget things like groceries right she's
got $500 for groceries she's not going
to spend that all in one shot let's
spread it out and make it more realistic
your most people go shopping once a week
so let's put it on Fridays $125 each
week perfect spread it out spreads it
out now it's not such a weight on her
paycheck you'll see that she's no longer
at the risk of overspending and so
that's how paycheck planning works it's
kind of like a fun puzzle that you get
to decide how you spend your money